O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
SIDETRACKED BY A STORM BY A
COMMENT BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
YESTERDAY HE CLAIMS WERE NOT
ACCURATELY REPORTED.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE LANGUAGE
USED BY ME AT THE DACA MEETING
WAS TOUGH BUT THIS WAS NOT THE
LANGUAGE USED.
WHAT WAS TOUGH WAS THE
OUTLANDISH PROPOSAL MADE A BIG
SET BACK FOR DACA.
MR. TRUMP RESPONDED TO QUESTIONS
TODAY AFTER A CEREMONY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HOW SOME OF THE PRESIDENT'S
FREQUENT CRITICS REACTED TO THE
REPORT.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS RACIST.
>> WE KNOW WE HAVE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE SOMEONE WHO COULD LEAD THE
KU KLUX KLAN IN AMERICA.
>> THIS IS SOMEONE WHO HAS
SUPPOSEN A PATH THAT IS RACISM
WITH STEROIDS.
>> PERHAPS THE WHITE HOUSE FEELS
THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS WILL
WELL RECEIVED IN SOME PART OF
THE COUNTRY AND IN THE
IT DOESN'T MAKE WHAT HE SAID ANY
LESS IGNORANT OR RACIST.
>> OUR PRESIDENT IS A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO NON-WHITE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
CRITICISM.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, JESSE, THAT
HAVE DISFAVOR WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAY HE IS RACIST AND HIS BASE IS
ALSO RACIST.
HE SHOULD NOT BE IN THE WHITE
>> THE LEFT SEIZED ON THIS, BUT
TRUMP GAVE THEM THE WEAPON.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE SAID IT.
IT WAS CRUDE AND RUDE.
I WOULD NOT SAY IT BUT TRUMP IS
OFFENSIVE.
IT SHOULD NOT COME AS ANY
SURPRISE.
>> AND ISSUED A DENIAL.
>> NO ONE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT WAS
SAID EXCEPT HIM IN THE PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM.
PUTTING THAT ASIDE, THE POINT HE
WAS MAKING THESE COUNTRIES HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT, I DON'T
BELIEVE ARE "S...HOLE"
COUNTRIES.
HE SAIDS IN MERIT BASED
IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE SAID LET'S BRING IN
PEOPLE FROM 3rd WORLD COUNTRY
AND THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO BRING
IN PEOPLE BASED ON MERIT,
WHETHER IT'S A HIGH EDUCATION OR
ENGLISH SPEAKING.
IMMIGRATION POLICY HE IS TRYING
TO PUT FORTH, THAT'S THE
PRIORITY FOR HIM.
WHAT GOT LOST IN HIS GAFFE THAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT.
THE DEAL IS HANGING IN THE
INTO THIS.
THE TAX CUTS WAS DOING GREAT.
HE HAD A GREAT MEETING AND HE
WAS GOING TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER ON THE IMMIGRATION
OVERHAUL.
NOW THAT'S LOST.
HE HAS TO DO A LOT TO REGAIN THE
MOMENTUM.
I DISLIKE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
YOU AND I KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN AT COCKTAIL PEOPLE, THEY
CALL MIDDLE-AMERICA "S...HOLE."
THEY ARE PUTTING PEOPLE DOWN WHO
LIVE IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
THEY CALL CHRISTIANS BAD THINGS.
WHAT DID OBAMA SAY?
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED HALF OF
THE COUNTRY DEPLORABLE PEOPLE.
THE REACTION IN THE MEDIA WHEN
THEY SAY TRUMP SAID THIS ABOUT
ANOTHER COUNTRY, DEMOCRATS SAID
HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT PEOPLE IN
OUR OWN COUNTRY AND HAVE NOT
GOTTEN CRITICIZED AS MUCH THE
PRESIDENT.
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT SAID THE
WRONG THING AND HAS TO DO BETTER
MOVING FORWARD WITH BLUNT TALK.
>> DANA, WHAT YOU DO YOU SEE
THIS?
THE COMMUNICATIONS BEING HANDLED
BY THE WHITE HOUSE IN RESPONSE
TO THIS?
THE NIGHT TO DENY IT.
THERE WERE REPORTS THAT CALLED
WERE MADE TO CHECK IN WITH
PEOPLE THEY WOULD LIKE TO TALK
TO AND EVERYBODY GAVE THEM THE
THUMB'S UP.
THIS MORNING THAT CHANGED AND HE
SAID THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE DEFENDING THE
COMMENTS.
EVEN IF HE DIDN'T SAY THEM, THE
COMMENTS ARE OKAY.
SOME OF THE DEFENDERS ARE SAYING
THAT.
AGREEING WITH WHAT JESSE SAID,
IT'S NOT EXACTLY SURPRISING THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE PROFANITY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS HAPPENED IN EVERY WHITE
HOUSE.
IN 2000 I THINK IT WAS PRESIDENT
BUSH SAID ONE OF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTERS WAS A MAJOR
LEAGUE A-HOLE.
>> THEN YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN WHEN
HE WAS ABOUT TO SIGN OBAMACARE.
THIS IS A BIG F-ING DEAL.
PROFANITY IS NOT THE ISSUE.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH AND WHO DO YOU
NEED TO HELP YOU DO IT?
SENATOR DURBIN, THIS MAKES IT
DEAL.
IT'S ABOUT THE SPENDING AND THE
CHIP MONEY FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH
INSURANCE.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS ON THAT SIDE
THE SAD THING ON TUESDAY THEY
UNTIL THE NEXT GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS DENYING HE
SAID THIS.
THE TIMING SHOULD HAVE COME
QUICKLY ON THE HEELS IDEA.
WHERE DOES IT GO FROM HERE?
THIS GUY SAID CHAIN MIGRATION IS
A RACIST TERM BECAUSE OF THE
WORD CHAIN.
LET'S NOT FORGET.
THAT THE BIG ISSUE THAT REALLY
>> THAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WERE A KID
AND ONE OF YOUR FRIENDS PARENTS
LETS HIM SEE R-RATED MOVIES BUT
YOUR PARENTS WON'T.
THAT'S FOX NEWS.
THEY WON'T LET US SAY THE WORD.
>> FOX NEWS IS THE PARENT?
[LAUGHING].
>> I ASKED IF WE COULD SAY THE
WORD AND THEY SAID WE COULD NOT.
>> THEY SHUT YOU DOWN?
>> YES, THEY SHUT ME DOWN.
THERE IS ALSO A SENSE HERE.
I DON'T APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
EITHER.
WHEN YOU HEAR IT, YOU GO, I HOPE
HE MEANS THE COUNTRIES AND NOT
THE PEOPLE.
>> DON'T YOU THINK THAT?
>> I AM HOPING.
I AM HOPING, BUT THAT HAS TO BE
ASKED IF HE MEANS THE PEOPLE.
HE NEEDS TO CLARIFY DID HE MEAN
THE COUNTRIES?
I HOPE HE MEANT THE COUNTRY.
HE COULD PROVE THAT BY SAYING
MERIT BASED IMMIGRATION CAN TAKE
PEOPLE FROM THOSE "S...HOLE"
COUNTRIES.
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE THESE 2
ARE BAD BUT PEOPLE FROM THERE
I FIND THE WORD TERRIBLE AND ALL
OF THAT STUFF.
I WON'T BE SELF-RIGHTEOUS.
WHEN I WATCHED THE MEDIA DO IT,
I CAN'T HANDLE HOW
SELF-RIGHTEOUS THEY ARE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE IF THEY WENT TO
A GYM AND THERE WASN'T THE RIGHT
SMOOTHIE BAR IN THERE, THEY
WOULD CALL THAT AN "S...HOLE"
ESPECIALLY IN NEW YORK CITY.
IF A GYM DID NOT HAVE A
PERSONALIZED TV IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY USES THAT WORD.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE
RHETORIC VERSUS ACTION.
RIGHT NOW NOTHING DONALD TRUMP
HAS DONE IN TERMS OF ACTION HAS
BEEN THE PROBLEM.
THE COUNTRY IS DOING REALLY
WELL.
WE HAVE HIGH OPTIMISM IN SMALL
BUSINESS AND PEOPLE ARE GETTING
BONUSES AND NORTH KOREA AND
THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
THE ISSUE IN THE MEDIA IS ALWAYS
A HEAVY LIFT FOR EVERYBODY.
IT'S LIKE A 4-HOUR DRIVE TO
DISNEY LAND RIGHT WHEN IT'S
CLOSING.
YOU DON'T GET AN HOUR RIDE.
>> [LAUGHING].
LAND WHEN IT'S ABOUT TO CLOSE.
AS LONG AS THE ECONOMY DOES WELL
AND HIS ACTIONS ARE GOOD, PEOPLE
THERE IS AN UGLY WAR OR
SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS, THEN IT
WILL BE AN ISSUE.
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THEY GOT.
>> PEOPLE ARE GETTING CAUGHT UP
ON SEMANTICS.
I DISAPROVE OF THE LANGUAGE.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW IN WHITE
HOUSE ADMINISTRATION OR
CONGRESS, EVERY WORKPLACE.
HOWEVER, HE BROUGHT UP ONE GOOD
>> THE LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WE ARE FOCUSSED ON THE LANGUAGE,
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS?
SHOULDN'T THE DEMOCRATS BE FAIR
AND FOCUS ON THAT?
THAT COMPOUNDED HIS RACIAL
COMMENTS YESTERDAY.
HIS OWN WHITE HOUSE DID NOT DENY
IT.
HE WAS WATCHING FOX AND FRIENDS
AND EVEN SUPPORTERS WERE SAYING
THIS IS UNFORGIVABLE AND WRONG.
THEN HE SAID I DIDN'T SAY IT
THAT WAY.
THE LANGUAGE WAS NOT QUITE THE
SAME.
I AM AMAZED HOW MANY REPUBLICANS
ARE PUT INTO THE DIFFICULT
POSITION OF HAVING TO DEFEND
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
DISTRACTING FROM THE AGENDA,
MAYBE IT'S INTENTIONAL.
REPUBLICANS ARE LIKE, LIKE PAUL
RYAN, IT WAS WRONG.
BUT THEY WON'T SAY THIS IS
CROSSING THE LINE?
>> YOU CAN'T SAY THIS ABOUT
FELLOW PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD.
HOW MANY AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HARD WORKING.
TO GREG'S POINT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE COUNTRIES.
IT IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
>> HE HASN'T CLARIFIED THAT.
>> ALLOW ME TO SPEAK.
THE REASON IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT WAS IN THE COURSE OF
A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE LOTTERY.
HE WANTS THE LOTTERY DONE AWAY
WITH.
IMMIGRANTS IN HALF.
SAYING IT SHOULD BE ABOUT MERIT
THERE WAS A SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE
COMING FROM CERTAIN COUNTRIES IN
THE NORMAL FLOW.
THE IDEA WAS TO ENGINEER IT TO
REPAIR AND CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD AS
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS.
HE SAYS WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
THE IRISH COMING FROM FAMINE AND
THE JEWS COMING FROM GERMANY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> SAYING THAT ABOUT PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
WE SEE ON THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
IT DOESN'T SAY WE WILL TAKE YOUR
BRIGHTEST AND RICHEST.
>> YOU ARE AGAINST THE MERIT
THING?
>> NO, LET'S HAVE A DISCUSSION.
WHAT HE SAID YESTERDAY WAS SO
OFFENSIVE AND WRONG.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT REPUBLICANS
AND EVEN TRUMP PEOPLE SHOULD
THEY ARE NOT ALL RACIST.
>> I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND HE IS
YOUR RUDE, RICH UNCLE.
>> IT SHOULD BE A MERIT BASED
SYSTEM.